queremos restar estos dos números mixtos
y como siempre lo primero que hacemos es
dividir estos números mixtos en una suma
y entonces lo que tenemos son siete
enteros más seis novenos menos tres
menos dos quintos ya ver aquí le puse
menos tres y menos dos quintos porque
este menos está afectando a todo este
número y recuerden que este número no es
más que tres más dos quintos entonces
este menos se distribuye y nos quedan
menos tres menos dos quintos o sea como
lo tenemos aquí y bueno igual que
siempre vamos a restar primero los
números enteros tenemos aquí un 7
-3 y eso lo que nos da es 7 344 y ahora
vamos a restar las fracciones tenemos 6
novenos
menos dos quintos ahora yo creo que
tenemos que hacer estas restas
fracciones en este espacio mejor tenemos
seis novenos menos dos quintos
y ahora buscamos el mínimo común
múltiplo entre 9 y 5 pues 9 es 3 x 3 y 5
ya es un número primo o sea que estos
dos números no tienen factores en común
así es que es un mínimo común múltiplo
va a ser la multiplicación de los dos
entonces aquí como denominador común
tenemos 9 por 5 45 45 entonces tenemos
la resta de dos fracciones con
denominador 45 y 9 por 5 son 45 por lo
cual tenemos que multiplicar 6 por 5 y
eso nos da 30 y ahora 5 por 9 nos da 45
entonces tenemos que multiplicar 2 por 9
y esos son 18
entonces lo que nos queda son 45 años y
son 30 18 y 30 menos 18 son 12
12 45 a vos 12 45 a vos entonces 4 12 45
a vos es el número mixto 4 y 12 45 a vos
pero todavía no hemos terminado esta
fracción todavía se pueden simplificar
más debido a que el 3 divide al 12 y el
3 divide al 45 entonces tenemos que
dividir tanto el numerador como el
denominador entre 3 ok y como estamos
dividiendo entre lo mismo tanto el
denominador como el numerador lo que nos
va a quedar es una fracción equivalente
entonces 12 entre 3 es lo que nos da es
un 4 y 45 entre 3 lo que nos da es un 15
así es que este número es igual a 4
enteros y 4 15 a vos
entonces este es el resultado